THE MOST AUTHENTIC ADS I'VE EVE
SEEN IN ANY CAMPAIGN.
JOINING TRAINING IS NOW WITH
REACTION FLORIDA SENATOR RICK
SCOTT IS WITH US.
FLORIDA HAD PROBLEMS IN 2000,
YOU FIX THOSE PROBLEMS.
IN 2016 OR 2018, I'M NOT SURE,
BUT YOU FIX THOSE PROBLEMS.
NOW FLORIDA CAN COUNT SEVEN AND
A HALF MILLION VOTES IN LESS
THAN FIVE HOURS AND NOBODY IS
QUESTIONING THE INTEGRITY OF TH
PROCESS AND NOBODY IS
QUESTIONING OR HAVING ANY DOUBT
ABOUT THE CONFIDENCE AND THE
RESULTS.
WHY ISN'T EVERY STATE DURING
THIS?
GIG IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE T
ME.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY FEELS GOOD ABOUT
YOUR ELECTION?
WE CONSTANTLY KEPT FIXING ARE
ELECTION LAWS FRAID I REMEMBER
IN 2018 WHEN THEY TRIED TO SEAL
THE ELECTION I GOT RID OF THE
SUPERVISOR ELECTION.
FIRST OFF YOU HAVE TO HAVE GOOD
LAWS WE HAVE TO ELECT THE RIGHT
PEOPLE TO RUN OUR ELECTION LAWS
SO THESE ELECTION, THEY MATTER.
THE SUPERVISOR ELECTION MATTERS.
THEN WE HAVE TO BE GOOD FOR
MONITORS, WE HAVE TO SHOW UP.
WE HAVE GOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO HELP HERSCHEL GO TO TEAM
HERSCHEL.COM.
TEAM HERSCHEL.COM AND YOU CAN
DONATE, YOU CAN VOLUNTEER.
HE NEEDS YOUR HELP.
WE ARE GOING TO WIN IT COULD BE
A MAJORITY, IT COULD BE 50-50
SENATE, THIS ELECTION MATTERS.
CAKE WOULD LIKE TO SEE, AND I
DON'T THINK I'LL EVER GET MY WA
ON THIS, BUT ELECTION DAY BE A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
YOU CAN MAKE EXCEPTIONS, PEOPLE
COULD VOTE ELDERLY, THE INFIRM,
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE IN
THE PRECINCT, I THINK THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS, BUT BEYOND THAT, IT
SHOULD BE A NATIONAL HOLIDAY,
EVERYBODY GETS THE DAY OFF AND
THEN YOU HAVE PARTISAN OBSERVER
WATCHING THE ENTIRE VOTING
PROCESS AND THE ENTIRE VOTE
COUNT.
PAPER BALLOTS, AND WE GET THE
RESULTS AT THE END OF THE NIGHT
IF IT SO SHE CAN CHECK IT AGAIN
YOU CAN TAKE IT A THIRD TERM,
YOU CAN CHECK IT A FOURTH TIME,
BUT AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THAT SYSTEM.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT THAT.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT VOTER ID.
I NEED AN ID TO BUY A BEER OR A
PACK OF CIGARETTES.
TO OPEN UP A CHECKING ACCOUNT.
TO GET ALL THOSE THINGS FRAID
FIRST OFF, WE'VE GOT TO GET RID
OF SHENANIGANS FRAID ANY CHANCE
OF SHENANIGANS WE HAVE TO GET
RID OF.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN ID.
YOU CAN'T DO BALLOT HARVESTING.
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE WE SHOULD
MAKE IT ELECTION DAY VOTING
BECAUSE THERE IS LESS FRAUD,
THERE IS LESS A CHANCE YOU CAN
VOTE ON MULTIPLE BALLOTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THE AGENDA I
BAD SO THEY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WIN UNFAIRLY.
EVERY TERM WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX ELECTION LAW
WE HAVE TO DO IT.
>> YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS
WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE LAST
THREE ELECTION CYCLES, LET'S
LOOK AT THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WE HAD DONALD TRUMP WHEN THREE
SWING STATES BUYS 70 PLUS
THOUSAND VOTES.
YOU HAD IN 2020 WISCONSIN,
GEORGIA, AND ARIZONA BIDEN WINS
BY THE VOTE COUNT OF 43,000
VOTES.
OKAY, WE ARE A DIVIDED COUNTRY.
WHERE DID ALL OF THIS PIE AND
THE SKY TALK ABOUT A WAVE AND S
NAMI ELECTION COME FROM BECAUSE
I NEVER SOUGHT?
>> HERE IS WHAT WE SAW.
WE SAW THE DEMOCRATS WEREN'T
GETTING THEIR VOTES OUT.
WE SAW AS WE GOT CLOSER, THE
BULLS GOT BETTER.
BUT ON ELECTION DAY OUR VOTERS
DIDN'T SHOW UP.
IT WAS A COMPLETE DISAPPOINTMENT
.
I THINK WE HAVE TO REFLECT ON
WHAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
I THINK WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH O
A POSITIVE MESSAGE.
WE SAID EVERYTHING ABOUT HOW BA
THE BIDEN AGENDA IS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN OF WHAT
WE STAND FOR.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS RUNNING GREA
HE'S GOING TO SAY HE'S GOING TO
REDUCE GAS PRICES COMING HE'S
GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REDUCE FOOD PRICES FRAID HE'S
GOING TO MAKE SURE WE GET SECUR
BORDER.
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE WE HAVE TO
RUN ON THINGS WE BELIEVE IN.
AND DON'T ATTACK REPUBLICANS
HAVE PUT UP A PLAN SAY AT LE